I probably want to interview Jeffrey
Sachs I probably want to what I what I
would want to ask him is what he is
proposing is same so clearly wrong too
many other sensible people in his field
that and it certainly is divorced from
my own experience seems to be ideas that
have been tried and proven to be
pernicious what is he thinking of now I
know that would be a loaded question I
have to find a nice way to answer it but
he won't answer to me if we really think
of international development is one of
the major issues that the world faces
I'd want to know what his hit what can
he be I really want to say what can we
possibly be thinking of but maybe
there's something in there that I'm
missing and the other one I would ask is
of modena John or somebody from Iran
what is their solution on Israel it's a
non-starter to say we're going to wipe
them into the sea going to New Clemente
stuff what is their solution what is
their proposal a serious proposal and if
they don't have one you know I try to
find that out
you